so I have a Pomeranian name is Jax 14
years ago I thought I was going to lose
him forever so he was a puppy I'm a
little kid and we were taking a road
trip my parents are driving I was
staying in the backseat his head was out
the window the wind was blowing through
his hair and then suddenly the wind just
carried him out the window
oh my god Jax I thought my dog was gone
and I don't know if you ever seen it
maybe white chicks it was pretty much
like literally like people seeing in
that movie at this point I'm crying my
mom is screaming my dad's try not to
crash the car but it turned out he was
still on his leash and I look outside
Jax is just loving it I'm holding her in
isolation he's just smiling the whole
time as the wind is blowing him against
the side of the car if I was in holding
on to him he would have been gone I
managed to reel him back in he made it
back safely he didn't even realize that
he wasn't so much danger even though
he's he's a lot bigger now super
protective of him if your dog is 1 pound
and he's staring at the window hold onto
him please
[Music]
you